maintenant donc un petit peu pour faire
plaisir parce que je sais que j'ai
beaucoup aimée museau 1er mai soit une
mise au point renaud muselier dix musées
au 1er ri donc en l'honneur de muse au
premier puis vous le prince d'orléans
mais vous êtes bien entendu que le
prince dans les rangs d un bon conteur
d'être à 6 ben voilà et l'a donc ce soir
votre invité suivant c'est le prince
napoléon
on vous appelle comanche à charles
napoléon prince monseigneur la peau napo
n'a comme pour vous le prenez votre
manière c'est toujours le même homme oui
donc vous n'avez pas de nan mais
sérieusement dans la vie on vous appelle
pour charles bien sûr ces dépenses je
vous dis monsieur napoléon par exemple
oui c'est très courant c'est napoléon
ça fait un peu gens un peu dingue quoi
ton est justement quand vous étiez petit
moment que ça fait petit à l'école vous
dites c'était trop grand c'était presque
injuste ce nom à porter c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est c'est lourd quoi par
rapport à ses petits camarades qui
s'appelle dupont ou durand c'est vrai
que les gens vous regardent dans la mire
du ferran bon moi j'ai plein de l'iran
qui ne croyaient pas sorti de la cuisse
de jupiter
donc oui mais c'est son grand-père qui a
changé tout à fait comment il s'appelait
des nations parce que c'est la famille
bonaparte
effectivement je m'appelle napoléon
parce qu'en effet donc que mon arrière
grand père a pris le nom de napoléon et
donc depuis nous nous appelons à douala
est en fait ceux qui sont dynastes
s'appelle napoléon et ceux qui ne sont
pas dina s'appelle bonaparte c'est bien
ça revient sur le concept mais c'est la
rentrée des classes je vais être prêt
alors on vous a invité d'abord parce que
jean marie bigard était là pour vous
révéler beaucoup et apprécier le prince
d'orléans j'ai beaucoup insisté mois
moi je viens semafo ça sur ce lien
personne ne voulait doux et un mille
feuilles qui est alors surtout surtout
et c'est une victoire pour moi le 17
septembre le 17 septembre
selon m
le 17 septembre charles napoléon va
briguer la mairie de aiacciu ah oui donc
là vous êtes top dans l'actu pas de
problème bien alors vous avez vous hâte
hélène ça vous disais non c'est un peu
lourd
c'est un peu loin vous êtes opposé à
josé rossi des ailes alors on voulait
qu'il soit là en face de vous pour vous
parler là il n'a pas mais on l'a eu au
téléphone voilà ce qu'il nous a dit
vous êtes opposés aussi à marc marc
angeli donc alors lui revend pas
délibéré rpr bonapartiste donc c'est
quand même extraordinaire c'est qu'il ya
un appeau léon contre les bonapartistes
a pas contre les bonapartistes moi je je
je je me présente sans l'appui de deux
parties et en particulier sans l'appui
des bonapartistes est fou pour un apport
est encore assez fou pour les
bonapartistes oui oui c'est un peu la
même chose donc on a eu au téléphone
marc angeli il a dit
voilà donc s'appelle un running gag ça
tue la vie tu marches un beau fils
google alors charles bonnet paris mais
napoléon 1er bon là tout le monde
connaît voilà on l'a fait l'année
dernière
alors dites moi un appel en premier avec
le temps quand même il apparaît beaucoup
plus négatif que la légende nous l'avait
appris d'ailleurs vous même vous avez
dit je préfère bonaparte napoléon
lorsque je dis je préfère bonaparte à
napoléon ça veut pas dire que je
considère que napoléon c'est rien du
tout nina je suis hostile à napoléon
mais vous comme un brillant d'arcole le
bras armé de la révolution au type qui a
fait massacrer des tas de gens etc a
laissé la france plus petit qu'il
l'avait trouvée quand même dans du point
de vue du regard que je porte sur
l'histoire de mon pays je parce que je
suis un républicain et un démocrate a et
venir je préfère effectivement la
période qui rappelle la révolution 89
d'accord sur tout ce qu'on peut
reprocher à napoléon parce que je crois
qu'on lui a fait beaucoup de reproches
récemment et plein de livres qui sont
sortis justement sur le nombre de
générations qui ont été massacrés sur la
france plus petite à la l'issue de
l'épopée napoléonienne que vous
connaissez bien et qui vous intéresse
d'ailleurs poivre d'arvor
alors surtout le moi je pense que la
pire erreur de napoléon c'est d'avoir
créé et l'allemagne parce qu'avant
l'allemagne les bourbons c'est commode
et très bien d'un émiettement de
l'allemagne et napoléon a exporté l'idée
de nation il a réveillé le nationalisme
allemand dont on a beaucoup souffert par
la suite vous en conviendrez non mais
c'est vrai et comme napoléon iii a créé
le nationalisme italien d'ailleurs c'est
à dire qu'en fait napoléon c'est lui qui
nous a mis d'allemagne sur le dos parce
qu'avant napoléon iv plein de petits
états qui était plutôt sympa à
fréquenter non oui alors si c'est une
c'est une c'est une relecture de
l'histoire c'est effectivement le point
de vue qu'on toujours défendu les les
monarchistes
c'est vrai que pour les monarchies
jacques bainville en particulier jack ma
vie en particulier c'est vrai que pour
les monarchistes l'idée de nation c'est
quelque chose qui va avec
je dirais l'idée d'une dictature avec
l'idée du fait du nationalisme tel que
nous l'avons connu au 20e siècle
mon point de vue de républicain n'est
pas celui là et je pense en particulier
que si je pense que une juge dans une
des grandes choses
un des grands événements disons de
l'histoire du xviiie siècle de la fin du
7e siècle et du début du neuvième
c'est justement que la france a été à
exporter au travers de l'europe
l'idée de république qui va avec l'idée
de nation ouais et parce que c'est quand
même moi je considère que c'est un
progrès pour les élections approchent
amenant facile ces gens-là nous tape
dessus une fois qu'ils ont formé les
nations c'est déjà un progrès après
après il ya l'utilisation qui est faite
du concept de nation mais on peut dire
ça de tous les régimes politiques c'est
à dire que on a des monarchies qui sont
requis sont je dirais démocratique il ya
des monarchies qui sont dictatorial
moins en moins longues dents tout dépend
des circonstances politiques qui
entourent le régime politique dont vous
parlez donc en l'occurrence vous
mettez-vous l'accent sur les aspects
négatifs et aurait été relativement
tardif c'est à dire attaché à l'histoire
du 20e siècle du fait national
moi je considère que la nation c'est
quelque chose qui a été un progrès par
rapport à la monarchie un mois a ajouté
patrick on peut ne pas aimer la police
mais moi j'adore personnellement mais
c'est un des héros de contes allemands
passent bien sûr mon appart et c'est
formidable ça on a tous rêvé d'être
bonaparte est en effet du pont d'arcole
mais napoléon c'est aussi le code civil
et c'est aussi un nombre d'inscriptions
ce sont les départements à mon avis
c'est ce qui est moins réussie mais
enfin ça dure encore 150 ans plus tard
j'ai une fascination pour napoléon que
je n'ai absolument pas pour son pour
napoléon iii république élu au suffrage
universel
quatre ans après
goode et heidegger et et excusez moi en
face a quand même été celui qui a refait
le paris moderne avec haussmann napoléon
iii très bonne idée très vague napoléon
iii est un peu alors justement moi je
serai l'avis contraire de patrick poivre
d'arvor se trouve napoléon iii être un
peu méprisé par rapport à ce qu'il a
fait et cause de sedan il ya eu ce dans
il ce don qui a été un point final
aurait point final particulièrement
dramatiques qu'ils ont c'est passé à
sedan mais ce nom s'est pris une tôle
j'essaye d'être mrc prg il trouve là ce
doit être très grosse défaite 5 à 0
mais c'est je crois ce ring 2 et 5 2 je
je je je crois pas que les trous noirs
basse et large on peut pas se garer à ma
cible ceux dont c'est une horreur mais à
cause de ceux dont il est le 14 18 à
cause de 14,8 ya eu 39 45
je verrai si on remonte dans l'autre
sens on peut aller jusqu'à doré m
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse sortir
comme ça d défaite de l'histoire et les
relier comme ça par des relations de
cause à effet je pense pas que à cause
de ce dont il ya eu la guerre de 14-18
parce que la guerre de 14-18 scellier a
beaucoup d'autre part entre un état mais
c'est dans le jeu coûte et l'alsace et
la lorraine
les 14 18 c'était pour le récupérer
quand même d'accord mais il ya eu bien
d'autres raisons que ces matières bauchi
je vous rappelle que grouchy manger des
fraises et qu'il est bel est pas arrivé
ouais des relents à cause de ça
aujourd'hui du des bonapartistes c'est
quoi c'est un peu auguste comte c'est le
positivisme c'est la devise du brésil
c'est ordre et progrès c'est ça non je
coûtais je n'en sais rien il faut poser
la question au ghana parti je n'ai pas
de point de vue sur cette affaire je
sais pas fermé le lundi
il est pas beau la partie c'est pas ce
que je sais ce que je sais c'est que heu
il ya napoléon bonaparte et le
personnage de l'histoire de l'humanité
qui a inspiré le plus d'écrivains c'est
vrai il ya aujourd'hui plusieurs
dizaines de milliers livre qui se sont
écrits et jeanjean que mon ami jean qui
leur prêtant qui a davantage de livres
qui se sont écrits sur napoléon
bonaparte que deux jours qui se sont
écoulés depuis sa mort bon et ça c'est
quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ça veut dire que c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui reste très
présent à la conscience contemporaine
qui suscite des choses qui suscite d
admiration qui suscite des passions
positive ou négative mais donc c'est
quelqu'un qui reste très très important
essor de france bien alors vous vous
êtes démocrates et républicains pas
républicain et crac et en votre père
apprécié pas tellement le fait que vous
soyez démocrate que républicain ça
allait encore mais démocrates il
l'apprécié pas tellement ça veut dire
que votre père le prince louis était pas
démocrate lui même non non je me
permettrai pas de porter ce genre
d'affirmation il est vrai que nous avons
eu des divergences d'appréciation mais
enfin je considère que lui c'est lui moi
c'est pas parce que vous étiez démocrate
je sais c'est pas c'est parce
qu'effectivement je souhaitais vivre
pleinement dans l'époque contemporaine
on y vient par fécamp assumer mes
propres responsabilités
alors vous en 68 vous êtes en terminale
à janson de sailly et là effectivement
vous claquer un peu la porte de la
famille vais connaître la vraie vie
c'est passé 68 ça a été ça a été pour
moi comme pour beaucoup de gens de ma
génération quelque chose de très
important ça a été géré dans un de nos
un régime qui était un peu un peu fermé
la fin de la faim disons du molise
c'était une explosion de de jeunesse de
de lumière de musique de tas de choses
qui ont bouleversé ma vie quoi donc
et donc effectivement j'ai j'ai
participé à 60 charles
oui et tout ça avant le sida moi je me
gare il ya pire rien je me casse il a pu
bien vous qu'est ce vous claquer la
porte vous partez de chez vos parents
vous êtes premier bonaparte à travailler
pour gagner sa vie
ben les autres oui enfin d'après leur
patrie ces avis bon vous êtes vraiment
bossé quoi je travaille alors vous
épouser une bourbon siciles mais manque
de pot elle est militante féministe donc
oui c'était vraiment une autre époque
à l'époque vous divorcez problème avec
papa évidemment et là vous épouser une
corse ce qui est pas une vraie idée
compte tenu des circonstances actuelles
et en 94 voire pire que tout vous
soutenez maxime est honni oui c'est
quand même bizarre parce que les
bonaparte
enfin il ya toujours une tradition pro
française au sein de la famille
bonaparte c'est là qu'on a toujours
soutenu la france plutôt que
l'indépendance de la corse
encore une fois je je je vous expliquais
tout à l'heure que je faisais la
distinction entre l'histoire et mon
engagement personnel bien voit bien donc
je vois pas en quoi je dirais mon
engagement personnel devrait être
déterminé par mais c'est quand même
impressionnant bien donc c'est tout à
fait clair
donc effectivement j'ai apporté mon
soutien donc à la liste européenne donc
de mes amis n'ont pas indépendantisme et
autonomistes corses des gens qui eux
défendent est la culture corse que je
considère comme très importante pour le
devenir de lille et en 97
votre père vous déshérite ait choisi
votre fils comme successeur un peu comme
le comte de paris d'ailleurs avait pas
choisi son fils et il avait son petit
fils tu le sais et on n'a jamais
retrouvé le pognon aux normes
oui je m'y attendais pas c'est vous a de
la peine à faire
oui sûrement parce que bon je veux dire
c'est ainsi c'est un choc d'apprendre
que finalement c'est tout ça et dans le
domaine du symbole bon mais je veux dire
je n'ai pas encore très bien compris de
quoi on m'avait concrètement privé si le
divorce maxime est honni
l'important 60 g j'ai bien compris il
est démocrate ben oui vraiment pris mais
j'assume bon et j'ai bien l'intention de
faire autre chose
un sumo dans la mesure où où j'incarnais
la modernité le fait d'assumer ce que j'
étais je comme vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure j'ai travaillé pour payer mes
études et pour être ce que je suis
aujourd'hui bon parce que ceci me permet
d'affirmer très librement mais mes
opinions politiques culturelles morales
et drogba 6 1 même si ça me vaut d'être
déshérités par mon père et ma tante à
vous avez fait un très beau coup 1 2
décembre parce que chez les napoléons
falloir tout se passe le dessin c'est à
dire le 18 brumaire celle de décembre
austerlitz de décembre le sacre de
décembre et le coup d'état de napoléon
iii 2 descend dans charles napoléon
qu'est-ce qui fait lui 1 2 décembre il
choisit quand même sa date avec un
certain sens du symbole faut bien le
dire et le 2 décembre
vous gagnez la présidence du souvenir
napoléonien qui est cette société
historique qui perpétue le souvenir de
l' empire
vous êtes le premier de la famille à
diriger de ce lien à pollonia et vous
avez du mal parce que là aussi il ya un
avocat varoqui revue avec le testament
mieux mais c'est tout ça c'est quand
même groupe ce sont des trois
conservateurs ouais précisément je n'ai
pas souhaité que cette société
d'histoire soit une société politique
donc c'est quand j'ai souhaité qu'elles
restent cantonnées à cet immense domaine
tout à fait passionnant qu'est
l'histoire de la révolution et de
l'empiré et non pas que ça devienne un
instrument politique bien alors
comment ça se passe un peu les choses
ajaccio là vous avez des bons sondages
donc je vais quand même contre vous marc
marc angeli qu'elle a depuis des général
des années quoi je veux dire aussi
qu'avec un renard il est malin josé
rossi attention hein
et vous vous arrivé là alors comment ça
se passe alors comment ça se passe eh
bien écoutez je vais j'ai commencé ma
campagne a depuis depuis quelques
semaines je suis tous les jours dans un
quartier différent d'ajaccio je vais
donc au devant des gens pour les
connaître pour connaître leurs besoins
pour qu'ils me connaissent eux-mêmes et
je dois dire que je suis très étonné
parce que je suis partout très bien par
contre non mais attends c'est le retour
de l'aigle dans la ville impériale
je suis je suis je suis surpris ouais
surpris je suis surpris par je dirais le
sentiment des gens qui a lui mettez vous
à la place
d'accord vous êtes vous êtes de cour
vous êtes qurna l'immeuble s'appelle
comment ouais j'ai pas pu éviter
bonaparte cours napoléon oui mais un
citoyen à part
oui mais c'est une ville dans lesquelles
les trois quarts des deux s'appelle
napoléon besoin il est difficile à
éviter
donc ça va aller mal et roula ça va
aller eh ben je l'espère serait pas
besoin de faire un coup d'état n'aura en
tout cas pas
et
bon la situation encore cela on va
parler un peu de la corse parce que
patrick ils en parlent tous les soirs
journal bien sûr nous comment ça va là
bas parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
les corses
alors c'est quoi ce il sait qu'ils se
hisser les deux cent mille personnes qui
sont là bas
qu'est-ce qui sinon il ya deux cent
cinquante mille habitants sur l'île et
ses 250 mille habitants vivent
normalement comme tous les français
on va à l'école comme comme dans toutes
les écoles de france on est soigné comme
dans tous les hôpitaux on roule comme
dans toutes les rues comme sur toutes
les routes de france
je veux dire pour la majorité de la
population il ne se passe strictement
rien bon donc je veux dire on vit
normalement en corse comme on vit sur le
continent et contrairement à ce que l'on
pense c'est un des taux de délinquance
or criminalité naturellement politiques
les plus bas de france et ce sont des
choses que l'on connaît mal enfin c'est
drôle comme phrase d'erreur apparaît mai
vraiment c'est le taux le plus bas que
nous n'arrivons juillet en corse il ya
eu 47 autres quarante et cinquante
assassinats homogène relayée par les
vacances c'est un peu la trêve c'est
tout le mondre en masse le pognon et
après ça reprend en automne et il ya
quand même il ya quand même dix fois
plus de meurtres directement coiffa
demorand moeurs et violemment suis quand
même c'est rarement les ménages et les
rues mais tout ça c'est plutôt la
chevrotine 1 qui ajuste aussi je ne suis
pas en train de dire qu'il n'ya pas
démordre encore bon c'est évident ça
serait signé l'arrêt mais je veux plus
que les autres départements français il
y en a il y en a sur sport peau du foie
puis sienna sensiblement plus en effet
que dans les autres départements
français mais ce que je suis en train de
dire c'est que pour la majorité de la
population corse contrairement à ce que
l'on dit et c'est vrai qu'un peu de ces
formations se séparent les médias les
choses et la preuve c'est que on a deux
millions de touristes chaque année qui
rentre de corse pour l'espérance pour
l'essentiel d'entre eux ravis de leur
séjour pour séquencer l'annoncé gens là
ne reviendrai pas ne reviendrait pas
s'il rencontrait comme vous le dites
d'écart et donc à une réalité qui n'est
pas la même que celle que l'on perçoive
ou 3 et la question un peu plus
directement notre sentiment en fait nous
vu d'ici 1 que les corses ils veulent
être libres dans leur système alors
système c'est quoi ces les clans si une
société assez féodal vous en conviendrez
c'est la langue corps bon c'est le
clientélisme l'intimidation voire la
mafia ça c'est leur système ils veulent
être libres à l'intérieur d'un style de
vie corse et en même temps elle pète
vraiment indépendant parce que comme
l'argent de la france qui arrive
les subsides ça y va pour deux cent
mille personnes en payent la tva à 5% la
continuité territoriale et c'est donc en
fait le sentiment qu'on a c'est qu'ils
sont à la fois ils veulent vivre comme
ils veulent avec leur méthode corse qui
n'ont rien à voir et la république est à
la fois ils veulent pas se détacher de
la france parce que ça leur rapporte du
pognon donc un moment fort et bien qu'
une décision qui soit prise parce que
comme disait jean marie tout à l'heure
sans vouloir jouer les chevènement enfin
où ils sont français et puis ils font
comme tous les français ils payent la
tva ils font l'indivision comme les
autres il faut enfin voilà ou alors ils
sont pas français ils sont indépendants
veulent pas non plus n'oubliez pas qu'au
jour n'oubliez pas que les
revendications des premières
revendications autonomistes
je ne parle pas des revendications
nationalistes mais les premières
revendications autonomistes au sens
disons de denman et de max simeoni
c'était des revendications justement
orientée contre le clan et il faut pas
oublier non plus que le clan a été le
mode de gouvernement de la corse qui a
été encouragé par la république car
depuis deux siècles que se passe-t-il la
république française ne s'intéresse à la
corse qu'au travers de ses têtes bon on
est d'accord et il est beaucoup plus
facile de cravo risée les clans et
d'envoyer à gimbelet les plantes et
ensuite les redistribue et en suisse
grâce à cela se font élire que de que de
que de gouverner la corse de manière
républicaine
par conséquent aujourd'hui l'immense
majorité des corses souhaite la fin de
ce système de clans et le retour à la
république alors maintenant vient se
greffer à ça la question du nationalisme
qui est la question posée par un tout
petit nombre de corses mais je tenais
discuter alors il faut inscrire le beau
temps non non non non c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai je ce point discute avec
des élus qui expriment une opinion
politique que je ne partage pas mais qui
sont des élus du suffrage universel
par conséquent ces gens là sont élus à
l'assemblée territoriale à partir du
moment où on ouvre une discussion avec
les corses on ouvre une discussion avec
tous les corses on peut pas dire on
ouvre une discussion uniquement avec
ceux qui partagent nos convictions
puisque par définition on ne peut
négocier qu'avec des gens avec qui on
n'est pas d'accord vous voyez un destin
quel destin vous voyez vous c'est à dire
vous voyez comme je parle homme qui va
arranger les problèmes encore ce maire
d'ajaccio c'est bien mais enfin c'est
dans votre famille il ya eu des destins
plus encore une fois je me suis fort
secteur de vous expliquer que eux c'est
eux et moi c'est moi donc vous les gars
vous êtes vous c'est que vous êtes
vachement bien jeu est content que ça se
calme à pau les ans il est bien l'autre
un père petit mais en plus il me dit on
me dit qu'un et il regarde parfois à
ajaccio on me dit ah ben dites donc vous
lui ressemblez clos train voulu
ressembler et si vous êtes maire est ce
que vous avez peut franchement je vous
pose la gueule comme ça est ce que vous
avez peur un jour de vous en prendre une
en pleine tête pas du tout mais pas
vraiment pas du tout dans la politique
enfin et si vous si vous défendez
vraiment la république et si vous dites
veulent à partir de maintenant on va on
va un peu se rentrer dedans dans le rang
vous n'avez pas peur qui n 1 qui vous
mettra un pruneau absolument pas parce
que je suis convaincu que ça rejoint le
le sentiment de la très grande majorité
des corses et d'une grande part des
beaux-arts mais bon sang le solfège et
musique il va vous mettre c'est la
minorité
chacun que je peux chacun assume ses
responsabilités et l'ordre reviendra
très naturellement encore très bien
jean napoléon alors on va on va passer
un petit questionnaire un peu plus léger
en tous les cas merci d'avoir répondu
série que vous ressemblez à napoléon
bonaparte veut plomb plomb votre arrière
grand père me semble énormément c'était
terrifiant les a pas qu'au 19e siècle
quand on le rencontre et plan plomb on a
pressé m en face du masque césarien de
napoléon visera un peu ce ce visage
c'est fou comment de après sa génération
elle ça ne le fait pas du tout non elle
reprend la plage des fils de bord bien
est ce que vous prenez des fois pour
napoléon n'ont jamais jamais japon vous
savez vous salaires ne bougent pas par
un jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à ces chiens peu plus et je fais
et tianma bouge évasif assez drôle c'est
une blague
blain alors on va faire d'interview psy
charquiya désigne alors l'interview psy
c'est simple est ce que cette mito la
vie tôt on va papa un vrai mythe ou quoi
c'est à dire le mythomane le mythomane
ah bon je croyais mangés par les mythes
non non le mythe hommage à ce serait
vite et les mythomanes c'est le mec qui
voit là ce sera bon intolérant je vous
ai répondu non est ce que vous êtes
schizo coupé en deux noms en 3
probablement oui mais pas que je suis je
suis en même temps corse français et
européens les est parano parano eu un
peu un peu à la limite un gg sentiment
que tu vois que que certains m'en
veulent ouais bon patron chez moi ce que
j'ai dit à la mêlée en priant et en
particulier ceux qui pensent que que
napoléon est toujours là parmi nous et
que et qu' il n'y a pas moyen de changer
l'histoire de bousculer les choses
d'avancer alors qu'il yad'autres naples
on sent un peu leurs victimes
oui maso maso a non pas du tout vous
êtes sado je veux bien faire mais arnaud
pas du tout j'ai reçu c'est à la fin
c'est marrant ça faisait mal de la ferme
a pas du tout absolument pas si jamais
envie de tuer quelqu'un
c'est dans le placement je suis donc une
victime toute désignée
est ce que vous êtes charte exhibo le
genre de mec qui se balade un peu comme
ça après elle sur son balcon assez
volontiers les sincères ce charme n'a
pas l'air très bien ça me fait plaisir
ça est ce que vous êtes métro le métro
goldwin meyer non métropolitains métro
n'ont pas dû je suis pas mais trop juste
circulent en deux roues moi mouais j'ai
envie de rouler ce pas vous êtes boulot
oui bien sûr voilà c'est oui vous êtes
quoi patron de la gnp veut quoi gérer
une période comme celle vous êtes dodo
beaucoup de dos ouais j'ai besoin de
beaucoup de sommeil beaucoup de sommeil
moi ça c'est le côté corse
si oui voilà c'est ça chez le 16e
souhaitait d'amour nom adam enfin
l'amour adam ou adamo est ce que vous
êtes à d'amour que j'ai déjà un peu
fabrice luchini est très adamou michèle
bernier très peu d'amour
vous êtes invités à d'un moment j'ai
arrêté ma tombe la neige commence comme
la neige tombe ou là mais je ne la vois
pas ce soir pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus